تصاعدت مشاجرة في
رصيف قوارب مونتغمري بولاية ألاباما خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع بين
مجموعة من ركاب القوارب البيض وموظف أسود
إلى مشاجرة ضخمة
أدت إلى اعتقالات متعددة.
ويدعو عمدة مونتغمري ستيفن ريد إلى تحقيق
العدالة لمهاجمته
رجلاً كان يقوم بعمله.  العمل، إنه
حادث مؤسف، وهو
شيء نقوم بالتحقيق فيه
الآن، وسنستمر في إجراء هذه
العملية قبل أن نتخذ أي
خطوات إضافية، بدأ كل شيء عندما كان
الموظف الأسود يحاول إخلاء
مساحة الرصيف حيث طاقم ريفرسايد
هارييت 2 ترسو عادةً، وكان الطراد على
وشك العودة إلى الشاطئ وكان بحاجة إلى
قاعدته للموت، كما تعلم أثناء قيامه بعمله
ولسبب ما
لم يعجبهم ذلك، ولم يرغبوا في
تحريك القارب
وقرر أن يتعامل جسديًا معه  يمكنك أن
ترى في الفيديو
الموظف الأسود على الرصيف وهو يتجادل مع أحد
الرجال من القارب العائم ثم
رجل أبيض آخر بلا قميص يهاجم
الموظف ويضربه في وجهه
بعد فترة وجيزة، ويمكنك رؤية العديد من
الآخرين ينضمون إليه  يمكن سماع هجوم
موظف المستندات في بعض مقاطع الفيديو الذي
انتشر بملايين المشاهدات
على متن القارب وهم يصرخون مطالبين
شخصًا بالذهاب لمساعدة الموظف،
ثم في وقت ما يمكنك رؤية
شاب قفز من القارب  السباحة
إلى الشاطئ لمساعدة الرجل الذي تعرض
للهجوم، اقترب القارب
ونزل الجميع، وعندها حدث ما حدث،
وهذا هو السبب وراء
وصولهم مباشرة إلى ذلك
القارب الأصغر عندما نزلوا من القارب، وذلك عندما تحول المزيد من
القتال إلى معركة شاملة.  -شجار شمل تعرض
العديد من الأشخاص
للضرب على رؤوسهم بكرسي قابل للطي
بعد فترة وجيزة من بدء الضباط في محاولة
السيطرة على الأشخاص الذين قيدوا أيديهم في
القتال، كما تعلم أنهم كانوا
الخصوم في الموقف برمته،
قم باعتقالهم لأنه لسوء الحظ عندما
تحدث الأشياء، فإن الأشخاص الملونين
أول من تم تقييد يديه،
لا تزال هناك العديد من الأسئلة حول الاشتباك الذي
بدا منقسمًا إلى حد كبير عبر
الخطوط العرقية، ونحن منخرطون بالكامل
ونبذل كل ما في وسعنا من العناية الواجبة
لمعرفة ما حدث بالضبط